john means
he was supposed to be the opening day
starter for the orioles
but because he was dealing with left
shoulder fatigue
he got a little bit delayed one out top
of the first inning flavor torres will
step to bed and this
offering gets labor torrence and it hit
him in the arm
torres moves to the left of the home
plate
circle goes down into a crouch and is
being attended to by a member of the
training staff those are the tough ones
to hit the forearm
sometimes can hit that nerve right
around your elbow
a chance here for giancarlo stanton with
a couple guides on and only one out
grounded shortly and through for a base
hit rounding third is judge here he
comes and the throw is gonna be cut off
it's an rbi single
for stanton and the yankees have a
one-nothing lead bases are loaded and
it'll create an opportunity for luke
voight
and the one-two high-fly ball
deep left center field giving chase a
smith and that ball is gone a grand
slam for boyd the ball just clears the
wall
and luke point with one swing makes it
five nothing
j hat last year 30 starts 12-8 with a
4-9 era
so the orioles have their lead-off man
on and that'll bring up
hancer alberto that's hit well way back
in left field
get out of here it's gone alberto with a
two-run homer this is how you answer
back after the yankees put a five spot
up and hansar alberto blows this one out
the o2 strike three so bounce back
so severino goes down looking the
orioles scored two on the home run by
alberto we go to the second
5-2 yankees rio ruiz coming up
louise in his first three games two for
12 on the year but both of his
hits have been home runs rio hits it big
way back and that ball is out of here
into the seats in the right center field
and suddenly
it's a one-run game how about you rio
talk about a good swing from the left
side
swing and a miss chase the pitch up and
out of the zone and pop
out of the inning flavor tours has left
the game as tyler wade takes over at
shortstop
louise delivers base hit into center
following in his two-run homer and his
last at-bat so well an
aggressive again at the plate
[Applause]
fly ball centerfield hicks
makes the third out so hap gets out
leaving a runner aboard
head into the yankee fifth inning it'll
be judge torres and stanton
the o2 swing and a miss off speed
has judge swing and miss
another bullet this one down the left
field line that's going to go into the
corner and he'll go to the wall
as stan picks up a two out double three
for three night
giancarlo stanton is hitting over 500
breaking ball and he got him
and stanton left in scoring position as
we go to the sixth inning and miguel
castro
takes over on the mound boyd with a
grand slam in the first inning
hits it hard past the third baseman in
the left field for a single
so luke voight two for three now
could be two nice play valencia for one
oh how about
you turn two pat velaka got it started
and then
alberto on the relay to first rain has
started to fall
at camden yards before we can get
started in the bottom half of the sixth
inning and so the tarp
has been pulled five four yankees is
resumed play here
rain delay one hour and 34 minutes
rio inside and it's a four pitch walk
for pedro severino
he takes ball four so back-to-back walks
from larissa and the orioles have
something going here
swinging a miss pitching the dirt
valencia goes down on strikes one way
another 3-2 payoff to ruiz a little slow
roll of the second
dj for juan de wade back to first double
play
how about that top of the seventh inning
here at the ballpark 5-4
new york richard bleyer on for the
orioles
talkman a left-handed hitter and he
grounds it to first base nunez is there
on a bounce and he'll walk to the bag
and that's one
very quickly and it's grounded slowly to
shortstop felika is there he gloves it
fires to first base that's two outs
another ground ball out
for richard bleyer here's the pitch and
it's a called strike three
and blyer strikes out judge booker
the yankees with two in scoring position
one down here
in the top half of the eighth got him
threw it by him a big strikeout for
gibbons
[Applause]
by him so back-to-back strikeouts tying
runs at first with one out
pitch home there's a swing and a deep
fly ball
down the left field line and it is fair
and good pedro savarino with a two run
homer and the orioles take the lead in
the bottom of the eighth
tying run at second and the go-ahead run
at first
aaron judge coming up to back and that
one's drilled to left field
there it goes see ya a three-run home
run for
judge and the yankees come back and they
lead this one
eight to six and the orioles are down to
their final out the o2
strike three and that will do it britain
retires the side in order
and the yankees win this one